there have been a lot of questions and a
ton of confusion about what Captain
America did when he went back in time at
the end of Avengers endgame how's it
going everybody it's Warren and one of
the most asked questions about Avengers
in game was what exactly did captain do
when he went back in time to see Peggy
knowing everything that he knew did he
stop Hydra did he save Bucky did he save
himself did he take the tesseract and
hide it knowing what it is and knowing
that Thanos would come for it one day
there are just so many questions that
Steve going back in time opens up but
luckily for us today we have some
answers as the writers of Avengers in
game have offered some clarity
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
have told us exactly what Captain
America did or didn't do when he went
back in time and I'll talk about it in
this video first big announcement I have
officially launched my personal YouTube
channel it's mainly going to be a comedy
channel I'll be doing some Avengers
skits on it pretty soon and be playing
some stupid games I put my first
official video up today you can catch it
in the link up above and in the
description down below would so
appreciate it and love it if you went
over and subscribed left a comment on
the video and we'll be doing some
giveaways really soon so by now we know
that the writers for Avengers in game
Christopher Marcus and Stephen McFeely
stand by the fact that there were always
two Captain America's in the main MCU
timeline and the fact that Captain
America was in fact Peggy Carter's
husband the whole entire time and the
father of her children according to the
writers Steve going back in time is all
about finishing his story arc in the MCU
that's it finishing his story so in a
recent interview this is what they had
to say Christopher Marcus said Stephen
and I are just so taken with the idea
that Steve went back and somehow their
fort has always been back and he got to
live his life because you get Captain
America loyalists who say that if cap
goes back in time he is honor bound to
fix everything he knows is going to
happen so he has to go save Bucky he has
to prevent the Kennedy assassination
he's a very busy man
but that's not why we sent him back we
sent him back so that he could become a
whole person and finally come home from
the war we didn't want him to go back
and just keep adventuring we wanted him
to rest
and the only way we could come to that
solution is if there are two caps which
I'm okay with
so basically what the writers of
avengers endgame just said is that
Captain America basically went back in
time and did nothing but live out his
life with Peggy Carter the whole purpose
of him going back in time and staying
back in time was to be with Peggy Carter
and to finally rest Steve Rogers had
been at war for years and years and a
years and at the end of Avengers endgame
it was finally time for him to get his
rest
that's why Steve gave the shield and the
mantle of Captain America to Sam and
that's why he stayed back in time so he
could be with Peggy Carter so for
everybody wondering if he went back in
time and he saved Bucky and he stopped a
president from getting assassinated and
he single-handedly took down Hydra well
according to the writers he didn't
because remember the writers also say
that when Captain America went back in
time he didn't go to an alternate
timeline he stayed in the main MCU
timeline therefore there are two Captain
America's in that timeline so therefore
this is how it has always been from the
very first Captain America movie there
have always been two Captain America's
and the one that's from the future that
goes to the Past just lets everything
play out because he knows how it ends he
doesn't need to save Bucky he doesn't
need to go save himself he doesn't need
to stop Hydra because he knows that the
current time Captain America will
eventually go on to do that and then he
will get to rest himself
so therefore Captain America did nothing
he just enjoyed the rest of his life now
we do know that Disney Plus is coming
out with a marvel what if series and we
do know that one of the episodes of the
what-if series is going to be what if
Peggy Carter was Captain America well
perhaps we could get a what if episode
of Captain America going back in time
maybe a what if he did change the events
of the past when he went back in time
definitely seems like something that
everybody would want but we'll have to
wait and see but in the meantime let me
know what you think about what the
writer said about Captain America really
doing nothing but enjoying his life at
the end of Avengers in game when he went
back in time do you think that Steve
Rogers could really sit back knowing
everything that he knew and do nothing
or do you think that he simply enjoyed
his life let me know what you think in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to go check out my personal
channel culture captains got my first
official video up today and
more funny videos coming in the future
as well as some giveaways and of course
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU and enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm
picking a winner at 500 thousand
subscribers coming up real soon also
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof